but we're going to start with some big
changes coming at the southern border
starting at midnight tonight the Biden
Administration cannot use covet as a
reason to expel migrants but as a wave
of migrants builds up along the border
the administration is launching a new
policy to crack down on illegal border
crossings just two days ago the border
patrol reported a one-day record of more
than ten thousand apprehensions and that
was before the title 42-42nd policy ends
mayors of some U.S cities along the
border have declared a state of
emergency as they are struggling big
time to take in the migrants Manuel
bojorquez is in one of those cities he's
in El Paso Texas with more on this story
Manuel good morning to you
good morning Gail when we spoke with you
just 24 hours ago from this exact same
spot there were tents lining the entire
side of this church with migrants
sleeping in them but this morning you
can see that's all gone and effort by
officials to move migrants to other
places but just on the other side of the
Border there are many more desperate to
come in
for many U.S bound migrants at this camp
on the Mexican side of the Border their
Journey has stalled
so she's literally hitting this link
over and over to try to get to a
calendar to book an appointment 14 year
old Anna Pabon fled Venezuela and made
it to the city of Juarez back in January
she has spent every day since then
constantly refreshing a U.S government
app in hopes of getting an asylum
hearing for her family but no luck
a lot of dangers along the way like what
she's one of many who have been waiting
for months some in shelters like this
anxious and determined yet unable to
even start the process
every day every day
but the Biden administration's new
policy could prevent tens of thousands
like them from Gaining asylum in the U.S
if they didn't seek it in another
country like Mexico first do not risk
your life
and your life savings only to be removed
from the United States if if and when
you arrive here under the new policy
Asylum Seekers will also have to pass
heightened standards or face banishment
from the U.S in some cases for up to
five years many will now be sent back
over the border to Mexico filling
shelters like the one run by Karina
Reseda what's your biggest concern I
guess given what you're saying right now
in the changing policy
um my biggest concern right now is that
we already have a backlog we are already
at capacity here on the Juarez side we
don't have the dignified housing for
people she says this shift in policy
will not deter migrants from attempting
to reach the U.S and all the countries
they've passed through and all the
danger they're facing here and
everything that's happened along the
journey nobody is going to
um immediately give up and go back
they're going to keep on trying their
resilient people
today the house is scheduled to vote on
a GOP scripted bill that would revive
some Trump era border policies such as
funding for construction of a border
wall and requiring businesses to check
their employees immigration status
President Biden has said he would veto
such a bill if it reaches his desk Tony
yeah Republicans themselves struggling
to pass it man what will work as for us
Manny thank you very much